all right welcome to another of these uh
stoic sunday sessions uh officially
titled stoic philosophy and practice the
basics uh a while back i decided to
start doing some sessions where we would
do a bit of a deeper dive into
classic stoic ideas looking at them in
some of the the key stoic texts and you
know getting getting clear about what
the stoics actually
did think and teach and do when it comes
to really key ideas and i began with
the virtues we had a session that was
specifically about all four of the
cardinal virtues and how they include a
lot more and why those particular
virtues and then we've done special
sessions on each of those four cardinal
virtues until
this one uh today where we are wrapping
up this you could call it sequence
with looking at the fourth of the
cardinal or key or whatever you want to
call them major
virtues
and we've looked at wisdom justice
courage already now we're going to be
looking at one that we can translate as
temperance or
moderation
self-control
i've seen other things as well
self-restraint
is a definition and people have all
sorts of
ways of translating this in english and
by the way it wasn't completely
consistent in the greek or the latin
either as we'll we'll talk about
and i think that
to start with this is this is a virtue
that often gets
short shrift right it's it's viewed as
one that's kind of boring by a lot of
people
you know it's courage that's very flashy
and justice oh that's the social
temperament and wisdom it's you know the
one that unites all the virtues together
temperance well it has to do with you
know the appetites and keeping things in
control and within limits and there's a
kind of boringness perhaps uh in a lot
of people's minds not in the actual
virtue but in a lot of people's minds
and then on the other side there are
people who seemingly want to reduce
stoicism
to temperance you know they don't they
don't think a lot they don't talk a lot
about the other three
virtues and they're into you know cold
showers and voluntary discomfort and you
know just being very restrained and
stuff like that and you know you should
think none of the stoic virtues work in
a
vacuum so
just being temperate for its own sake is
kind of losing sight of what temperance
is really about so there's a lot for us
to look at i'm going to be referencing a
number of key stoic texts in particular
you know we've got the three big stoic
philosophers i'm really only going to be
talking mostly about one of them
although you can find lots of important
discussions of things connected with
temperance in epictetus and in marcus
aurelius i'll be talking about seneca
but i'm really going to be focusing much
more
on
two really important expositions of
stoic philosophy both by non-stoics one
arius didymus's epitome of stoic ethics
the other diogenes laertes um
lives of the philosophers the life of
zeno contained in book seven and then
some stuff from cicero and also some
stuff from musonius rufus epictetus's
teacher
who i think doesn't get as much love as
as he could use right and so we're going
to look at what they have to say about
temperance and how we could apply that
in our own life you know i'm gonna talk
for maybe 20 25 minutes you can write
questions in there if you want to i
will probably not pause to answer
questions unless it's something super
super relevant and pressing
but we'll definitely have plenty of time
for q and a and discussion
at the end and
before we start looking at what the
texts say there there is something
there's a few other things i want to say
about temperance as a virtue
one of these is something i probably
should have said
at the very beginning of each of the
sessions
and it's it's this all these virtues the
stoics didn't come up with these in a
vacuum right the stoics are kind of
johnny come lately on the scenes when it
comes to schools of philosophy in fact
you know xeno himself is drawing upon
the cynics and the plaintiffs and the
megarians and then developing his own
synthesis the stoics articulate their
philosophy in part in contrast to the
epicureans but the aristotelians and
some others as well
and everybody had been talking about
virtues for centuries before the stoics
come on the scene right so
you know
there's the recognition and you can say
depiction and advocation of temperance
in mediterranean and near eastern
culture going back
centuries um not necessarily millennia
it kind of depends on the text that
we're looking at
and so you know there's a recognition
that you need to remain within limits
you might think about the delphic maxim
you know made ain't again you know
nothing too much that that kind of
figures into that
and there's also some explicit analysis
of what temperance is within pre-stoic
philosophical traditions
um not only you know
people who know their philosophy would
like to think of aristotle's nick mccann
ethics book three
um and also you know plato's discussion
for example in the republic book four
as well as other places but you know we
know from
the lives of the philosophers that this
was important for the the cynics this is
important for others
the epicureans talk about temperance as
well so the stoics are stepping into
a conversation that's been going on for
a long time
another thing that i do want to point
out is that the typical
treatment of temperance and if we take
aristotle is like a paradigm for that
um it has to do with appetites and or
desires for pleasant things the
epithelia in in greek right and an
aversion to a lack of pleasure being
sometimes addicted to pleasures or not
being able to do without them
and you know the paradigm cases for
aristotle are
food right and and eating too much
eating too rich of a kind of food
um
he says drink wine right but he he's
really got in mind intoxicants so we
could you know in our culture think
about other kinds of alcoholic beverages
we could think about marijuana we could
think about other intoxicants and then
for the greeks majorly important sex
right sexuality but we could also think
about what you know uh plato and
aristotle talk about as entertainments
you know things that we look at like you
know what binge watching netflix we
could think about um the clothing that
we wear you know is it is do we need it
to be really nice do we need it to be
fashionable and we go on and on and on
about other things that we can
be
you know
captivated by addicted by you know as
mark says um indulgence is a word that
we can use here things that we can
become self-indulgent with
and this is something
here's a third point before we begin
we live in a time
when
you know it there is a tendency
given all the other crappy things in our
life the things that we don't like which
from a stoic perspective might be
indifference but you know perhaps are
affecting us
to use pleasure as a kind of
compensation you know um we often call
it self-care oh i'm gonna like have you
know think about the prototypical thing
in movies where somebody's had a bad day
and they come home and they get out the
tub of ice cream and instead of like
spooning out a reasonable amount into a
dish and then eating that they're
sitting on the floor eating the whole
half gallon or gallon of ice cream right
that would be an example of the sort of
thing that we're we're sometimes prone
to and we said oh i've earned this right
and so
this is all you know kind of within oh
mark twain's events i think it's called
retail therapy yeah people do this with
uh purchasing and it's interesting
because temperance also extends to
wealth uh in in some respects uh at
least for the
the stoics so
um
let's start with a passage from seneca's
on the happy life
he says occasional experiments of our
moderation give us the best proof of our
firmness
and virtue a well-governed appetite is a
great part of freedom and it is a
blessed lot since
no person can have all the things that
they would have we may all of us forbear
desiring what we have not it is the
office the purpose of temperance to
overrule us in our pleasures some she
rejects others she qualifies and keeps
within bounds i think this is a sort of
typical portrayal of temperance right
and this goes to the thing i was talking
about a little bit earlier the
boringness right it's a temperance is
kind of a check on us it says no no you
can't have that and this you can have a
little bit as a treat as the meme goes
right uh it's okay for you to have a
little bit of drinking but you know
maybe you have to stop at two beers or
you can have that that tasty food over
there but only a limited amount and you
know when we look at some of the general
discussions of the four virtues
i think this also bears this out to some
extent
seneca and you know the famous letter
120 tells us
about the virtues uh the desires had to
be reigned in fear to be suppressed
proper actions to be arranged debts to
be paid
they we therefore included
self-restraint or temperance bravery
prudence and justice assigning to each
quality it's special function so once
again we see you know desires had to be
reined in because otherwise they're
going to go crazy right
um arius didimus tells us that
practical wisdom deals with appropriate
acts
self-restraint
deals with a person's impulses right so
again we see temperance has to do with
desires and impulses
cicero in on duties book one tells us
all that is morally right arises from
some one of four sources it is concerned
with and he goes through it and then
when he gets to temperance he says this
the orderless orderliness and moderation
of everything that is said and done
wherein consists temperance and
self-control
so again you know
with that one though we see a different
element being introduced it's not just
about restriction it's not just about
you don't get to do what you want you
know smacking that don't do that uh you
know sort of self-restraint
now it's about something that i think
cicero really is good at bringing to the
table
orderliness and moderation of everything
that's said and done later he's going to
talk about a kind of harmonization
taking place as well so that's you know
general discussions
and now i want to get into something
else that we haven't explored that much
in some of these other virtues we did
with courage to a certain extent
ariastitimus has a has an analysis of
the emotions that is quite good and we
can supplement this with seneca we can
to some degree with with passages from
say epictetus
and you know other texts as well um he
tells us that we've got
epithumia or appetite is how he
translated it's often translated as
desire one of the four basic passions of
the soul
and he tells us that it's a desire
orexis in greek
that does not listen to or obey reason
the greek is much more simple a pathe
logo
pathane is to listen to but it also has
the connotation of obeying
and so what this means is that this this
large category of emotion
desire or appetite has a cognitive
aspect to it and it forms the opinion or
the judgment in greek dokzadzin
you know the word that we get doxa from
uh you know which we often see
translated in stoic texts as not just
opinion but judgment
the opinion or judgment that something
is good so when we think rightly or
wrongly
that something is good our desire
reaches out to it and you know if we
so think about for example
our sexual desire which is something you
know
rooted in nature but certainly
culturally formed you walk through a
supermarket you get up to the front and
all the you know magazines are there
showing people scantily clad you know
how to get your beach body and stuff
like that you're like oh that person's
good looking your desire is reaching out
to this imaginary person who's been
photoshopped and you don't even know
from adam right
or you know think about food commercials
you see something like oh that looks
good yeah that's your epithumia reaching
out towards it
now for the stoics desire as uh aries
tells us includes anger and its
different varieties and that that's a
whole different interesting topic but
they do distinguish between different
things then he talks about cases of
erotic love
violent cases of erotic loves cravings
pothos which is actually also translated
as greek or as grief in other texts
yearnings and then all these philia
fondness for pleasure philodenai right
filos means sort of friendship or
affinity towards so uh feel feel hate on
i is affinity for pleasure we like
pleasant things fondness for wealth
fondness for esteem or a reputation
philadelphia right
and
then so that's one category right and
then he talks about pleasure hidoni
another one of the really basic emotions
for the stoics and he calls this an
elation of the soul that does not listen
to or obey reason this also has a
cognitive aspect it says a good is
present
it thinks that things are good in
response to which it is appropriate and
the word there is very interesting
cathay k which is the same word that we
get appropriate actions or duties from
the cathaycon
and it says that it's it's it's
appropriate to be elated to enjoy to to
do that sort of thing and very
interestingly
arius only discusses three examples of
this he talks about joy at others
misfortunes
common problem right
uh gratification in the unexpected
and then what gets translated as
charlatan re
which i think is a bad translation
pleasure in visual deception and you
could think of it as pleasure in
deceiving others but also pleasure in
being deceived now diogenes laertes adds
to this by telling us that it also
includes what what gets translated as
ravishness ravishment uh calaisis
pleasure charming the ear think about
how much enjoyment we get out of you
know music
the light terpsis the mind's propulsion
to weakness he calls it and then
transport diagus unbinding or the the
you know the breaking down of virtue
and you might say well that's that's all
very interesting what the hell does this
have to do with temperance
well these are all forms of pleasure or
desire that temperance would bear upon
and either rule out or limit or wean us
away from and you might say well what
about the other i know that the stoics
had like a four-part emotion
classification what about the other
parts and the answer to that is well
that has to do with courage
there's like a
sharing of responsibilities you could
say between courage and temperance in on
the happy life seneca tells us
as the body is to be kept in on the
downhill and forced upwards there's some
virtues that require the rain pulling
back and some that require the spur
right
um in liberality temperance gentleness
of nature we are to check ourselves for
fear of falling but in patience
resolutions and perseverance where we're
to mount the hill we stand in need of
encouragement so temperance handles the
things where our our body and our mind
along with our body is tempted to like
go out there and get more and all that
the pleasant things right
and
courage helps us deal with the painful
things the things that we'd like to
avoid
going on a little bit further diogenes
also tells us
um
the cologne the the
valuable in itself the beautiful has
four types and he uses the word
cosmeone there orderly we can translate
it and and you know this is clearly for
him a synonym
for the temperate because he uses
sofrosun a temperance just after that um
i've brought up this passage a number of
times from diogenes laertes book 7
chapter 126
if a person has virtue they can figure
out and do what ought to be
done
and so they can establish kind of rules
for themselves or guidelines for
themselves and these are the the poetia
things that are to be done and these
include what should be chosen
uh which have to do with wisdom those
which should be endured which you have
to do with courage those which should be
distributed which you have to do with
justice and then those which have to be
as we translate it stayed the greek is
amenitaia restrained is another way of
thinking about it and so when we do
things
steadily
amenity
amenity
in greek
diogenes also distinguishes
this is something
stoic virtue is not just
itself it includes some sub-virtues
and you think of it as like a bucket
that that contains a number of different
things he only talks about two but these
are both very interesting terms eutoxia
and
cosmeotes
so eutoxia toxis is ordering arranging
right
and
a temperate person isn't just
self-restrained by
denying themselves pleasures or holding
themselves back or you know
making themselves not have a piece of
cake or something like that it has to do
with arrangement it has to do with
priorities it has to do with structure
um coast meal tastes also you know this
comes from the word cosmos right which
means not just like the universe but it
also means order
and beauty structure
and so you can see these are these are
connected with each other to be a
temperate person
is not just to be a self-denier it's to
be an arranger a prudent arranger
now when we look at um aries didymus an
arius denimos gives us these wonderful
breakdowns of the virtues that don't
include every single thing the stoics
thought about it but in it they're great
starting points he actually
distinguishes um four different
components of temperance and two of
these are the ones that that diogenes
has already mentioned right so let's
start with the first one eutoxia what is
eutoxia what does that mean
so arius didymus tells us that it is
knowledge of when something must be done
and in what sequence
and overall of the order of actions now
the the in what sequence what literally
what after what t meta t in greek and
the last one the overall the order of
actions this is a really interesting
phrase in greek it's calcatholo in in
general right uh taste toxios tontoxion
so remember how i mentioned tox you know
toxis toxios is ordering this is the
order of orders
that's part of what eutoxia or
orderliness
um
has to has to do looks like we have a
unstable connection it is staying here
uh
so let's give it just a minute until
we reconnect ah there we go it looks
like we had an unstable connection
moment for a minute let me restate what
i just said
in case anybody didn't get it so um the
order of actions is actually a
translation of the order
of order rings a meta ordering that's
what eutoxia is that's part of
temperance
now the next one
cosmeototis it's translated as propriety
this is a little bit more simple
knowledge of
suitable and unsuitable motions
literally motions uh cane salem
um and the the greek word there is
prepucin
so
you know what is what is befitting what
is right for the occasion
um
uh yeah no it's cosmeotase
in the greek um
but so this is this is a key component
as well
then we have something that i think a
lot of people would typically associate
with uh
moderation temper and self-control en
cratea
uh literally self-control self-mastery
right and this is also
mentioned by diogenes and now this is a
really interesting one knowledge which
does not overstep the bounds
of what has come to light in accordance
with correct reasoning right so there's
a lot of moving parts there right so
let's let's break this down
does not overstep the bounds literally
doesn't go further than it should right
on upper bottom binomial is to walk or
to step hooper is over and anuper would
be to like go go further beyond so it
doesn't go beyond okay that's that
sounds like the temperance that we all
know and love doesn't it
um but it doesn't overstep what so he
says it doesn't overstep the bounds of
now it's translating what has come to
light literally what has appeared
fonentone
very important because
you know fontasia
plays such a major major role in stoic
uh discussions fontasia are what you
translate as appearances or impressions
also imaginations so you know the stoics
think that we we have to use fontasia
rightly and this is part of how we do it
now you're the third component to this
tone cataton ortho logon right so
orderthon logon is right reason
a straight reason literally so it's not
just reasoning because our reasonings
can be full of bs right we can reason
how i should have the fifth piece of
cake or eat all the ice cream or cheat
on my wife and you know go go
be with this woman over here or sleep in
all day right we can reason those sorts
of things orthos logos right reasoning
says no no no no that's that's a
rationalization
not a correct reasoning
so
and kratea's self-control is dependent
on actually thinking through what you
ought to do it's not as if it gives a
rule once and for all i mean there are
some rules don't cheat on your wife ever
there's never going to be a good reason
for that
but maybe sometime you should have the
fifth piece of cake right if you're at a
cake eating contest maybe then you you
abrogate that rule right
now there's a fourth that i it's
actually third in the list but i i made
it fourth because i just wanted to
close off this little part by talking
about it
ido mosune now if you know your greek
you know that idos means shame or a
sense of modesty and this is often
translated ido mosune as modesty i want
to point out too that epictetus thinks
that this is important too but he uses a
slightly different term
um
actually a couple different terms at
different points
so um what is this this is knowledge
which is able
as uh diet as uh areas as
now that's a weird way of saying things
isn't it knowledge which is able to a
correct reproach
so
now this eula betike
this
is connected to another stoic term which
means
caution
you label right
so it's not just about avoidance it's
about being cautious it's about taking
care
taking care
not a criticized
but it's not about being criticized per
se it's about being correctly
criticized once again we see that word
orthos in there
so if you think to yourself you know
here's a good example
well what would socrates or what would
zeno or what would epictetus say about
my behavior here they're correct
reproachers right what would
any pick any celebrity you want or what
would my neighbor down the hall say
about it they might not be correct
reproachers you have to you know figure
out how you would guide yourself to not
be reproached by the people who actually
count the people who know what's bad and
what's good so temperance has got a lot
of a lot of stuff to it doesn't it so
far um
we're actually getting a little bit
overtime so i might i might just skip
over some of the missonia stuff
actually i'll just reference lecture six
he talks about training and he tells us
there's training for the soul alone and
training for the the soul and the body
and he says we use the training common
to both of these when we discipline
ourselves to cold heat
thirst hunger meager rations
pleasures and patients under suffering
and now notice the connection between or
the split between temperance and courage
again right for by these things and
others like them the body is
strengthened and becomes capable of
enduring hardship sturdy and ready for
any task the soul too is strengthened
since it's trained for courage by
patients under hardship and for
self-control by abstinence from
pleasures
right
and so then he says training which is
peculiar to the soul consists in seeing
the first of all that the proofs
pertaining to apparent goods and not
being real goods are already at hand and
avoiding
things which only seem evil
uh
and in not pursuing any of the things
that would seem only good so there's two
components there right knowledge
of what is good and what's evil practice
in doing that and then he says by doing
that we become courageous and temperate
right so very important stuff there um i
also want to bring up cicero and if
you've if you haven't read on duties you
really do want to check that out because
that is cicero giving you stoic ethics
with some you know roman culture stuff
mixed in
and he's got a whole section on
temperance or moderation
in book one
interestingly
where do you think he would begin
he starts with talking about building
houses
and
right so this actually ties in with
something that aristotle had talked
about
in terms of um magnificence how we use
our wealth and cicero actually uses that
term in here
he's sucking magnificence under the
virtue of temper
he also tells us that there's three
things that are important for choice of
action if we want to be virtuous one is
that the impulse the apatitus the latin
version of the greek epithelia should
obey reason so reason giving the right
amount of care for the value of
objection not getting super worked up
over stuff that's trivial
realizing that stuff that's important we
need to give importance to the dignity
of a
decent person i'm translating liberalism
that way rather than as gentlemen to
give it a bit more broad sense to it and
he says that the best way we can do this
is to observe
propriety staccus means like you know
what is appropriate um you know when we
talk about decoration by the way that
comes from dekus right and a lot of
really in
uh
cicero's idea
he makes a distinction
between um because he talks about the
uses the greek term eutoxia right
he makes a distinction between
translating that as just moderation
modestia and then what he calls orderly
conduct ordinance conservation the
preservation of order which we can also
he says call modestia and he tells us
that this is a science or knowledge
scantia
doing the right
thing at the right time and he tells us
now this this actually will answer some
of the questions that are coming up
everything in our life should balance
and harmonize it's not just a matter of
appetites
having another unstable connection not
sure what's going on with the internet's
here uh unfortunately but let's take a
little pause until we can be sure
that uh things are are coming through
um
boy i don't know what's going on with
with this but the internet gods seem to
be uh unhappy with how things are going
um
so
in the meantime well it says that we're
waiting till we try reconnecting uh
which could be on youtube's end could be
on my end could be who knows
what
um
there's a lot of people asking questions
by the way about um uh terminology
um
you get the books and and and check that
out this is a you know this is a long
pause right here i'm not sure
what is going on with the internet are
people hearing me if if you can weigh in
and uh say yes i'm hearing you fine that
would be awesome
if not then we'll have to pick up where
we're missing out on stuff um
not quite sure what's going on with the
uh
the modem here on on this end
okay so mark says in and out but hearing
most of it well that's not that's not
good because that means the recording is
not hearing uh things properly
either
um
clifford says loud and clear all right
well let's let's continue on
and uh maybe youtube is um
wrong about the connection being
unstable who knows you know you never
know what these platforms so let's let's
talk more about cicero um cicero says
everything in our life should balance
and harmonize and the latin for that
is this beautiful phrase envita omnia
since opta into say at convenientia
so everything should be adapted opta
between itself right
and
everything should coincide everything
should harmonize convenientia coming
together
literally everything should be able to
come together within our life so it's
not just a matter of restraint it's not
just a matter
of not doing things you know
there's a whole bunch of of
you could call them little readjustments
that have to take place
another thing that cicero tells us that
i think is very interesting
is that we should be leery of violating
social norms
just because we appeal to
examples like socrates or aristippus
we're not necessarily socrates right so
just because something was okay for
socrates to to break or or violate
that doesn't mean that it's necessarily
okay for us we have to exercise prudence
in order to be temperate and he actually
tells us that we should reject the
system of the cynics entirely why
because it erodes what he calls
moral sensibility or vericundia
in the latin
the last passage that i wanted to pick
out was with seneca's on the happy life
and i'm just going to actually
go through this rather quickly so we can
start answering some of these
questions
happy is the man that eats only for
hunger and drinks only for thirst that
stands on his own legs and lives by
reason not by example and provides for
use and necessity not for ostentation
and pomp let us curb our appetites
encourage virtue and rather be beholden
to ourselves for riches
than to fortune for when a person draws
themselves into a narrow compass they
have the least mark on
at them let my bed be plain and clean in
my clothes too my meat without much
expense or many waiters and neither
a burden
to
my purse nor my body nor to go out the
same way it came in throwing up right
problem with the romans that which is
too little for luxury is abundantly
enough for nature so this is a quite a a
um you know
passage to to think about temperance in
and it also shows why we ought to be
temperate it gives us a kind of
freedom and that's that's a very
important thing for the stoic so let's
take some of these uh questions
and comments um
massacres says do you think to achieve
temperance one can or should supplement
the stoics account of temperance with
other philosophers
how to achieve it heidegger's being in
the world if so with who so heidegger is
going to be totally useless for you on
this um being in the world just means
being in the world there's nothing
intrinsically temperate about that and
many people's way of being in the world
is actually tied up with idol chatter or
stuff like that so put heidegger out of
your mind and what i would say in
response to the first question is this
first learn what the stoics actually
have to say about temperance and
work it through to its end that means
spending a lot of time with the classic
stoic texts and spending a lot of time
practicing this
then worry about whether you need to
supplement it because you don't know
what they offer until you've really gone
through it you know so
an hour a day a month probably isn't
enough to
to make that that call
you probably need to devote quite a lot
of time before you're actually going to
reach the limits of what the stoics have
to offer and you can say the same thing
about the aristotelians the same thing
about the platonists and you know
there's there's a long platonic
tradition and the same about um even the
epicureans i would say
um
let's see
mark smith says what would dr sadler say
i am not the stoic sage and i am not a
particularly virtuous guy so i should
not be the person to provide the
criterion for
uh right criticism you could say right
uh massacre says first time hearing of
this didymus fellow well i mean
that's a sign that you want to start
studying this stuff more um if you've
been in any of these other sessions we
have cited arius didymus a number of
times and you'll see me in my my
writings on stoicism bring him up quite
often because he's a quite interest
quite important text
clifford says is temperance more about
control of oneself or balance neither
it's it's about a whole bunch of things
as we've looked at so far it's not more
about one than about the other it's a
complex
set of uh
sub-virtues
that all kind of reinforce each other so
there isn't really a more here
kitten melon can you list the names of
the texts you mentioned especially in
reference to the soul
yeah i mean i did this at the top of the
hour
arius didymus is epitome of stoic ethics
diogenes laertes
lives of the philosophers book seven the
life of zeno
and i've done so throughout the thing
seneca's on the happy life
cicero on duties
um lusonius rufus's lectures
uh i think that's pretty much it for the
ones that we have referenced in this one
well seneca's letters you know so
those are all of those
um
[Music]
let's see here
kitten melon so why are courage and
temperance separate
because they're handling different
things you know courage has to do with
how we deal with pains and as you know
if you've looked at the previous session
a whole bunch of other things as well
perseverance dealing with fear uh
temperance has to do with reining in
desires with arrangement of of things so
that they they fit in with each other
each of the stoic virtues has its own
area that it's working with and this is
something that you can say about any
virtue ethics you know take for example
aristotle's virtue ethics which does not
just use
the four cardinal virtues but you know
breaks it down in a different way why
does he have
you know say
ten different virtues that are being
discussed in books three and four the
nick of mccain ethics because each one
deals with a different subject area if
they dealt with the same thing and they
had the same things to say about it you
would blend them together and they'd be
the same thing so anytime that you see
um a real virtue ethics as opposed to
the schlocky stuff that people try to
sell out there
as virtue ethics or they just name a
bunch of stuff off anytime you see a
real virtue ethics
you should look at the virtues that they
they distinguish and also you could say
this about the vices how are the vices
different
well they orient the human person
differently
in relation to the subject matters
um
let's see here
saxon
uh i may have asked you before about the
book character strengths and virtues a
handbook by classification by martin
seligman and christopher peterson
i don't trust seligman i don't trust the
positive psychology stuff um so
you know i i've dealt with positive
psychology people and life coaches and
i'm pretty leery of the self-reporting
aspect of what they work on so
you know i'm not i'm not a big fan of
seligman
um
[Music]
you know if it helped you a lot
great um i if we're like playing around
with psychologists i would say i prefer
daniel goldman who's probably a lot more
aristotelian in his approach you know
kitten melon what to do if you fail at
being temperate
get get your butt up and figure out what
you did wrong and start fixing it
same thing for any moral failure right
um
for the stoics understanding what's
going on with yourself is really
important you you don't want to just
like
um
you know
it's not stoic to
just keep repeating the same thing you
have to think you have to apply your
your mind so that you can
figure out where you're going wrong
start looking at your assumptions i mean
you notice that with this discussion
of temperance there's an awful lot of
cognitive aspects to it right
mark says advertising seems uh purpose
to incite that grasping of desire you
mentioned
do you think that advertising and
consumer culture is fundamentally
antagonistic towards temporary customers
yes that's completely correct
and this is one of the main criticisms
that has been made of advertising for a
very long time
interestingly in business ethics it
tends less to be framed in terms of
temperance which is a virtue ethics
approach and much more in terms of
deontology it gets framed much more in
terms of
autonomy interfering with the autonomy
of the decision maker by provoking their
desires you know i mean a prime example
of this
i remember seeing when we were watching
the you know last nfl football season
all of these advertisements
for getting into crypto with celebrities
and i was like oh this is bad you know
this is not going to be
good
um because there's all these people out
here who clearly make bad decisions
because we've been you know seeing other
advertisements pitch to them for
betting online or stuff like that
and you know
now they're pitching crypto as something
that like you can't afford not to get in
on and so what is that appealing to
desire in the form of greed
fear fear of being left out of something
you know perhaps there's also the sort
of fear of like not appearing like you
understand how this this crazy stuff
works
and
you know
that's that's a prime example
um of people being suckered into things
and you know the thing that makes people
the most vulnerable is when they think
that oh no no i'm too smart to be taken
in by the con
you know and and advertisers love
customers like that that think that
they're way
smarter than they are and in the stoic
sense not just you know like cognitive
intelligence but better having better
habits right
all right um
clifford so then temperance is using
control of oneself to maintain or find
balance that's a thing that it is it's a
whole bunch of things as i've said i
would i would very much advise against
trying to reduce temperance down to
a single phrase
the whole purpose of this thing was to
unpack for you how many
different aspects temperance has but
that is certainly part of it and the
using control of oneself yeah the stoics
think that we
do have the capacity
to
rework our thoughts about things and our
habits and our volitions
so
if you want to become temperate you have
to actually come to know yourself and
know yourself as the messed up thing
that you are
so that you can start using that messed
up thing that you are to work on it and
make yourself
less messed up
saxon says uh never read anything else
by seligman the book is like a car
repair manual or things are laid out in
a different way than their typical
presentations to philosophy yeah i don't
doubt that because seligman uh has got
his own shtick going you could say
mustafa i've been following you for
nearly a decade wish to discover this
channel of yours long ago
okay so
um you must have been following other
stuff because the channel's the main way
i think people know me
christian thanks for making this series
of videos i learned a lot i'm working
through some of the works you've
recommended so far just finished
diagonalization last week and really
enjoyed it well that's great yeah and
you know interestingly
coincidentally
we are still going through diogenes
lierte the life of zeno the summary of
stoic doctrine in the mke that's
milwaukee stoic fellowship uh month by
month
um
all right rick says temperance now looks
much broader and subtle that's right
yeah thanks to your explanation the
cognitive aspects are particularly
interesting yeah and each of these
here's one of the things i want to say
so the stoics don't in the discussions
of this give us like
checklists or
lots and lots of practices
with worksheets or stuff like that but
we could
develop that sort of thing i think you i
think a person could
develop something like a robust stoic
virtue ethics developmental curriculum
it's interesting that
nobody's really doing this
in a as far as i can tell
systematic way there's lots and lots of
people out there marketing like you know
become your best stoic and stuff like
that but it's all kind of slip shot and
much of it doesn't have a lot of
connection to
um the actual texts there's a lot of
like glomming things on to each other
like saying you know you've all seen the
stoic compass [ __ ] chart where it's
like you know the epictetus is three
disciplines which by the way that's just
epictetus that's not a that's not a like
across-the-board stoic thing that's just
epictetus and epictetus actually has a
different three disciplines and seneca
has three different disciplines too in
ethics so we should be very very leery
accepting uh even if pierre aldo is in
favor we should be very leery of
accepting that and then those three
things tie in with the four virtues
[ __ ] those sort of schematic
approaches we actually talked about this
at stoicon in a panel
that's for suckers that's not real
stoicism that's like somebody made a
nice image that they could use and it's
it's going to be detrimental to people
who
you know think that that is um
where where we're going you know in
terms of development so it'd be kind of
cool to to develop some sort of real
curriculum like this
um
steven says would be worth noting
there's a great joy and strength and
this is very very important very good
point
great joy and strength maybe even
inspiration and being temperate which
stoic would discuss this the most seneca
seneca discusses this plenty i mean i
already brought up you know some of the
passages in which he does from on the
happy life
um he talks about this in his letters
epictetus talks about this as well you
know these positive aspects of like
being in control of yourself yeah it
feels good
not to be
prey
to
your own desires not to be powerless in
front of them that's that's really quite
important
um
all right saxon's making another book
recommendation
uh chaldani's influenced the psychology
of persuasion wrote it to help regular
people protect themselves from marketers
um yeah okay
that's that's good mark says you
mentioned the relevance of temperance to
intoxicants could what we've discussed
be brought to bear
in helping out substance abusers and
addicts is addiction and issue of
temperance or something more so that's a
great question
and this actually ties in with a broader
question that comes up in terms of
stoicism like i saw somebody in a stoic
group posting just yesterday
can stoicism help me overcome my severe
depression and the answer is no because
it's not designed to do
that kind of work
it's not about overcoming it
it would be it can help you deal with it
right but you're still going to be a
depressed person and maybe there's
chemical imbalances or stuff like that
with addiction
you know we know that some some
substances are are physically addicting
they mess up your brain where you want
to get that stuff
and some of them are um habit forming in
a
more psychological way you know
like um
you know take marijuana for example not
really physically addicting but boy do
potheads love to smoke pot you know and
some of them can't do without it right
um and so
um
i think what we have to be
careful of is first of all drawing a
really strict line between and this is
goes to quantum astrologers thing
stoicism is not a lifestyle attitude
rigorous system of philosophy if if you
have in mind a lifestyle attitude that's
a totally different thing than actual
stoicism
can virtue ethics help us deal with
things like addictions or trauma or
um you know other things that are that
are really
psychologically significant in our life
yes they can certainly help us with that
they are not by themselves the be-all
and end-all that will take care of
everything any more than like you know
when people get religious and spiritual
counseling and they're like god's going
to help me with my addiction god will
help you part way or the religious
teachings or whatever but you also need
to see an addiction counselor or you
know go to 12 steps or something like
that
these things can work in common with
each other not perfect harmony but you
can use them
as different uh
um you could say sets of tools to really
help yourself out
um
the same thing by the way goes not just
for stoicism but also for aristotelian
philosophy there is a wonderful
wonderful article out there by leslie
cosman called on properly being affected
which you can find anthologized in a
number of different you know collections
on of essays on aristotle including
amelie rory's collection
essays on aristotle's
ethics in which cosmon says
that what aristotle provides us with is
something that's really quite helpful
but it would need to be supplemented
with some of what spiritual direction
provides and some of what depth
psychology provides and when you do that
sort of thing you get something much
more powerful i mean if you think about
the contributions that stoicism made to
albert alice's rational emotive behavior
therapy you can see something kind of
like that right cbt by the way um you
know in the hands of people like uh tim
labon and and and uh donald robertson
who are you know very reversed in stoic
philosophy very connected to stoic
philosophy the average cbd person not
quite so these days so
um
enzo says i'm late to the chat so pardon
my question is regular basic as a person
recently interested in philosophy where
should one begin with the stoics i have
an entire video out there that you can
google uh self-directed study stoics
right and put that into google and
you'll have a video that
breaks these things down for you
um
christian is offering advice on that but
again there's a whole video i also have
a piece that i wrote recently stoic
reading suggestions which tells you why
you should begin with these particular
three works
and then move on to the next three works
and stuff like that i should probably
put that into the video description
going forth i should mention another
thing too
um so now that we've done these these
five stoic sundays and talked about the
virtues i think there's still more stuff
to be plumbed in terms of the stoic
conception of the virtue but we'll
probably uh leave that off i do have
something coming up on a different
platform than youtube there's a link to
it right there
in the
video description
about a
free course free 90-minute session that
i'm offering on light hall
and it's specifically about five stoic
practices from epictetus's and caribbean
we did a previous one on light hall with
five stoic practices we're doing another
one with five more stoic practices so if
you want to do some real hands-on stuff
um and get you know questions answered
about the end caribbean which is which
is a good place to start it is one of my
own places where i start beginners um
you might want to sign up for that same
same time on a sunday and light hall
looks to be very promising as a place to
offer
these sorts of engagements so all right
mark says my final question seems to me
the term suffrosine has a rich etymology
i particularly like plato's dialogue the
karma days which which is trying to
define sulfurosine
not successfully as is the case
but uh could you maybe speak
about a possible link to phronesis um so
you know throne is in both of them
i mean clearly for both plato and the
stoics
temperance sofrocinae
is connected with phronesis practical
wisdom
you know practical wisdom helps guide
phronesis or helps guide suffrosine or
or moderation
um you know for the stoics and for
for plato and they're both pretty
socratic in this way i think you can say
that
um wisdom or practical wisdom
is you know sort of the
the
the
first among equals of the virtues right
so it's it's it's performing this
absolutely important guiding role
um and you probably can't have much
temperance you could probably have some
temperance but you can't have much
temperance without also developing
practical wisdom and to go back to some
of the questions about you know where
where courage and temperance you
you really need both of them so that you
can handle the kind of life situations
that you're going to run into
justice you know you could say maybe
justice helps to dictate some some
some of the limits that that
temperance has to observe
so for example
if um if it's okay for you to eat a
certain amount
most of the time and you keep yourself
to that amount but now you're in a
situation
where you're stuck in a bomb shelter
with a bunch of other people
and you have sufficient foodstuffs and
they don't
you probably need to eat less and
distribute more right so so temperance
would look a little bit different
depending on the situation and justice
might have something to do with that
right
so all right well this is a good place
to leave off hopefully this has been
useful i'm you know sorry about the
internet interruptions that we've had
which are really unfortunate
um
still says it's unstable hopefully
everybody's hearing okay and hopefully
the recording of this is okay
we'll take one more question here my my
friend thinks stoics are more close to
deontology than aristotle's virtue
ethics i disagreed with him what are
your thoughts
totally depends on how you understand
dantolo
totally depends on how you understand
aristotle's virtue ethics totally
depends on you know which stoics you're
looking at so there isn't a cut and
dried answer for
for that um aristotle has some
deontological aspects to his own
philosophy that you can find when you
look at nick of mccann ethics
particularly book four i think or is it
book two where he says some things are
just wrong like adultery you know you
can't have the right amount of
adultering
screwing around on your wife or anything
like that
so all right well i will see all of you
hopefully uh next week for the thing
which isn't in youtube but on light hall
the link to which is below
and hopefully this has been useful for
you and
here we go